tonight around the world film theaters
in London England
CEDA Mikasa in Rio de Janeiro Brazil
movie temples in Tokyo Japan
Flickr balances and Sydney Australia
picture Piazza in Rome Italy
the seniority in Paris France
and along the Great White Way of New
York New York
everywhere theater marquee live
the names of people now gathering in the
music center of Los Angeles copy
for the 55th schedules look cata me
award
brought to you by
blah repla the people who help make the
world a little more beautiful and GE at
GE we bring good things to life and the
coca-cola company and your local
coca-cola bottler for big refreshment
coke use it and Polaroid makers of the
unique light mixing Sun cameras and 600
high speed film this is the plaza the
Dorothy Chandler Pavilion for the public
in the pressed cheer of the arriving
nominees and participants at this year's
ceremony
including Walter Matthau one of the
board distinguished host of tonight's
show Superman himself mr. Christopher
Reeves Charles Durning nominated as Best
Supporting Actor Margot skips one of
Hollywood's busiest actors
ben kingsley up for a Best Actor Award
for his role as guppy
tonight's presenters Robert Preston Best
Supporting Actor nominee for
victor/victoria Steve Guttenberg star of
diner also presenter tonight Sir Richard
Attenborough a candidate for Best
Director
backdrop Tom's silicon hilarious Carol
burnin each will play the role of
presenter tonight Jessica Lange nominee
is both Best Actress and Best Supporting
Actress young Matt Dillon star of The
Outsider
the beauteous Raquel Welch ooh tracer
stage as a presenter tonight another of
tonight's scheduled presenters talented
Eddie Murphy
Best Supporting Actress nominee tarragon
mr. Dean's visa nominated as Best
Supporting Actor for the verdict
here's Lesley Ann Warren nominated in
the Best Supporting Actress category
nominated as Best Supporting Actor Louis
Gossett jr. can a presenter during
tonight's festivities chair
in the theater the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences protects the
55th annual the Academy Award Orchestra
under the direction of composer
conductor bill Conti
and now here are Liza Minnelli Dudley
Moore Richard Pryor and Walter Matthau
there are billions of stars in the
galaxy sparkling and twinkling away and
thousands of stars here in hundreds who
were in the movies each day there are
hundreds of stars in the whole tinnitis
earned our respect and praise but just a
few will have when we're through
there are thousands of craftsmen and
women too loaded with technical skills
all do their part for the state of the
art and of the 417 films they made there
was many a worthy try
the posted suppressor promotion the pain
and the panic
the
there were 2,000 tuxes and cummerbund
waiting for people to wear and 500
hairdressers flying around blow-drying
everyone's hands
and it all comes down to this together
it all comes down to this the press the
promotion the pain and the panic the
love and elation
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences wider producer fay kanin
good evening and welcome few weeks ago I
ran across a newspaper account of the
first Academy Awards in 1929 a quiet
little dinner for about 200 people at
the Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel the
awardees had been announced three months
before all the honored movies were
silenced and the statuettes were handed
out by Academy president Doug Fairbanks
in the whirlwind time of four minutes 22
seconds well we're going to be a bit
longer tonight and the quiet family
dinner has to become an event watched by
over 300 million people around the world
but one thing hasn't changed the Oscars
are still given to movie makers by movie
makers a recognition that being good at
what you do and taking pride in it is
something to be proud of in a world that
sometimes forgets to value that above
fame or money each of our nominees has
helped to put on the screen something
special that speaks to people moves them
delights them in the unique way that
only movies can just how unique was
brought home to me recently when we
visited the house in Amsterdam where
Anne Frank and her family had lived we
climbed up into those attic rooms that
contained the lives of eight human
beings for two years everything was
intact and I noticed pinned up on the
wall of Anne's room some faded newspaper
clippings when I went closer I saw that
they were pictures of her favorite movie
stars I don't think I understood till
that moment what a powerful role movies
can play in people's lives and that part
of what had kept joy and hope alive in
that young spirit were memories of the
movie she had seen that makes me doubly
proud of this evening of the films and
the talented people that we're about to
honor and most particularly
of this remarkable twentieth-century art
form in which we who make the movies and
you who watch them are so affectionately
joined thank you
before very engaging people who opened
our show in song I'm going to return as
our host for the evening and to guide us
through the first Awards we have a
wonderful actress who took her own house
Oscar home were there Liza Minnelli
thank you my goodness this is a very up
night and if you think it's exciting
here you should see what's going on
backstage
Richard Dudley and Walter are still
rehearsing our opening number they they
felt they sounded too much like the
Beach Boys anyway it's Oscar time and it
all does come down to this the night
that separates the men from the boys the
women from the girls clients from the
agents
anyway as you know custom dictates that
we explain the voting procedures so here
to read the rules here is mr. John
mashita thank you miss Minnelli the
voting procedures work like this all
elective Academy murmurs but vote on
nominations for the five picks of the
other night mrs. Bend by members of each
Academy branch for example right of
seminary by dozens of your active
feminine active directors have any
correction etc they don't remember send
in those nominations to select the final
Awards after they have signed in the
final Awards they send their secret
ballots are sent to the Academy's
independent accountants Pricewaterhouse
of tabulation foreign langu talking
metric short films makeup sound effect
editing a visual effects of the only
exception only members to attend
comprehensive special screenings may
vote for them result in order price
water has until the sealed envelopes are
open here tonight thank you
thank you very much during the next
commercial break John will Rita's war in
peace know the Academy thanks to
representatives of Price Waterhouse and
here to well to introduce you to the men
who guard our destiny are the strong and
silent Frank Johnson and Steve Kaplan